This is right
The tempo just...
Wait...
This is so hard!
Aah this works well!
Yeah it’s...
Hey guys
try this one!
What!?
Yeah just try it out!
I’m sure it works!
Do a cartwheel
Who did I hit?!
Keep on keep on!
You ready Lassi?
Yeah I’m ready!
Check this save
Look at this!
Water break!
Good let’s go let’s go!
Come on!
Why...?
Okay Otto let’s finish them!
Still in play!
Noooo!
What a point!
If you catch it
you get ten dog biscuits!
It’s actually quite handy
the handle there
Or not
He got it!
First
hard
and then slow
Super bouncy ball!
Straight in the face!
It wasn’t even close!
Just throw the cucumber at me Emil
Are you sure this is the best option?
Best option
NO
Option
YES
Oh perfect!
So it’s working
Now we know it’s working
Cucumber blood
Well done guys!
Just like my meatballs
Yes
we got it!
Well done Miikka!
Yeah great!
We got it!
Ghost serve!?
Best of three
Everybody because everybody best of three!
Okay!
If you have a really big table
and one Pongfinity net isn’t enough
you can just use this simple hack
That’s actually true!
So I think we found some pretty good...
I need to prepare myself you know
You got to see where the ball is coming
Keep your eye on the ball!
You ready?
I think so!
I wasn’t even ready for that!
Keep your eye on the ball man!
Stop micromanaging me!
Get more pop on your spin!
Got it!
Still got it!
Think we’re done!
Let’s go find out
A snowman!
Yeah that’s a snowman!
Yeah!
Can you do this with a...
Player Tennilä
Heads or tails?
Tails
You serve!
There’s mental support
Whenever someone hits subscribe
at the office we’re daily
smashing the gong!
All the time we’re following the follower count
Everytime someone subscribes, bang!
It’s a nightmare but it’s worth it!
I’m not really sure about this but let’s try!
Make the biggest chocolate...
And we’re gonna make the biggest chocolate racket
ever made
out of
chocolate
Ping pong racket
Chocolate racket
You heard it you heard it!
You know what to do!
Oh no no no!
Can we have one each for sympathy or pity?
The zero one...
because that’s how I feel about myself...
Venice beach...
Skatepark*
Venice beach skateBARK
You say it!
He broke the chair!
I was just testing if the bench works
Okay I think I’m done with this!
One zero!
Player O’Connor
scores!
Okay Otto let’s go!
This is pretty intimidating!
Good save Emil!
Real Madrid if you’re watching this
I’m available for a few million
Where is he!?
I will do it now!
🎵Pretty woman🎵
🎵Walking down the Santa Monica pier🎵
🎵Pretty Otto🎵
You should always check under table tennis tables
before you start playing because
there might be crazy axeman!
And Emil Haaland
Strikes the goal!
You can do it!
Yeah yeah yeah
Yeah we need some dance moves from Miikka!
🎵Emil rapping🎵
This one was wet!
Good match!
Thanks!
What!?
How is that possible!
Never felt that much pressure with such a bad serve!
Sorry!
All good!
Let’s see who has the best touch for some balls!
I would have made it for the second one aswell
Five more!
Four more!
Stay tuned!
This is the one!
It was actually really close!
One!
Two!
Three!
Go!
Guys
Remember to hit subscribe!
You can see the subscribe button right here!